i don't know how much money mion is
bringing to america and how much he's
got saved myona and i have not discussed
finances which is huge and it's very
important especially when a lot of the
pressure is being put on my shoulders
los angeles is a dream that is
obtainable but not right now and i hope
that she can just follow me in this
direction of staying in south dakota
being more conservative with our money
and understanding that we're thinking
about the long-term goal not just the
present
i know you don't want to be here in
south dakota but you can consider us pop
saving funds and and having a marriage
here
i want to leave their journey i really
don't i don't know what's the nicer way
to say this but if i wanted a small city
life i could stay just here in asia
should live that type of life i really
don't want to to come to america and
live like a 50 year old
i'm sorry
no i'm not asking you to we're not going
to be living in south dakota for the
rest of our lives i'm just saying six to
12 months and possibly getting married
here when you tell me about gay marriage
that sounds even worse than living in
south africa because getting married is
one time to life and i really wanted to
be really special i totally agreed on
the beach wedding i don't know why
you're changing it now
it's not a big of a deal
miuna is thinking about herself with the
wedding and she's not quite thinking
about my perspective because when she's
often talking about i want the city life
i hear her talking about i instead of we
this is a marriage now we're coming
together and we're joining as one as a
force so this is where we need to
compromise and sacrifice for one another
i mean i could be recording an album
with my band
but instead i've moved back in with my
parents just to get myona to the united
states
do you love me enough to stay in south
dakota for 12 months
how does that have anything to do with
how much i love you of course i love you
but
i could stay in serbian with my parents
that's not nice of my lifestyle
so that was a no to my question
not what i said don't change my words
please
[Music]
you